and remind people I am talking to you
right now not to set up firing you I am
talking to you right now to set up the
turn that will make you get promoted
which is actually true here I believe
what's working for me most is saying hey
Archie need to talk to you first of all
you're incredibly lovely there's a lot
of things that are going well this is
the key to everything Arch and this
might be an unlock for you in my
subjective opinion because we're just
human beings this is where the humility
comes in to the best of our knowledge
from what we've seen and gathered from
the eyes of others and ourself we think
you suck at cce's when you add that you
are only doing the best you can on your
subjective opinion no different than
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
however you are required to manage In
This Moment there's something that takes
it from being absolute truth to your
absolute truth but you're required to
deliver it that I think is landing and
something for you to think
about